the name for our next award Mudbox might
sound messy but in fact there is nothing
messy about it it used to be that to
create a creature the artist would have
to build an armature sculpt clay around
it
cast it then decide if it was right and
start over if it wasn't it was
time-consuming and I was expensive
Autodesk Mudbox mug box mud box is a
software that provides a high resolution
sculpting and painting tool set which
artists used to create high-quality
digital digital characters it does this
at a price that's that smaller
productions can afford mud box provides
artists with intuitive tools such as
brushes and stencils for crafting
surfaces it bypasses the problems of the
real world such as scale casting
scanning and even gravity thus the
Academy presents its technical
achievement award for the concept and
design of mud box
- Andrew commish Daniel Carr David
Cardwell apologized
Tibor my Medawar and for the implication
implementation of mud box - Chava kaha G
and am already mayor please well we have
a passion for this industry and for
visual effects and it's a deep honor to
be here with you tonight I'd like to
thank the Academy for recognition of our
work and the award this evening we were
very grateful I'd like to thank the
entire dev team for their amazing work
and for the support of my family yeah
thanks yes my box has benefited from
some contributions the work of many
talented designers and engineers and so
I'd like to thank specifically John
Schrag Ian Tom Moline Stephen Yee Chris
Hanlon
ELISA Fung tobias official Shi Cheng Bao
and his team for their for their
fabulous work on a personal note I'd
like to thank my my family for their
unconditional love and in support over
the years
I'd like to thank the Academy for the
generous award being an artist winning a
technical award is quite overwhelming I
had a wonderful team to work with and we
had a very talented user base the Mudbox
project became so much more rewarding by
making tools not only for ourselves what
we did in the beginning but to make
tools body for our fellow artists
between the early beta testing ended up
being thousand five hundred because we
couldn't say no I also like to thank to
my wife Brenda who supported me all
through this project and I hope this
award will inspire my children Skye and
my daughter Maya to find their passion
in life which will be working on movies
of course